standards flow from aged age and
everything evolves and changes including
human nature and the truth itself if you
were here and recall I used as my
example of that that great historian
progressive historians comment about the
Declaration of Independence to ask
whether the philosophy of the
Declaration of Independence is true or
false is essentially a meaningless
question that's relatives but the
founders it turns out hold that held
those organs to be self-evident self
evidence I would argue in the way that
Aquinas meant self evidence when he
wrote about it what they understood be
self-evident all men are created equal
and so have equal rights uh Neoga rights
endowed by their creator and found in
human nature itself which is say
American constitutionalism makes no
sense and has no legitimacy outside of
the Declaration of Independence and it's
grounding in the rights of human nature
the title of our talk tonight comes from
that same document life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness I note that that's
not the lock in formation formulation
which was life liberty and property but
happiness an interesting choice of words
Jefferson picked pointing to higher
things by picking the classical word
happiness one surely meant by that that
Liberty which the Constitution says is a
blessing in particular he meant a
religious liberty understand the
American idea of Liberty and it's most
practical sense in its highest sense
means we must study human nature or talk
this evening because once again Thomas
Aquinas provides guidance rich guidance
about the nature rights and the nature
of happiness
well the Thomas Joseph White is the
director of the domestic Institute the
Dominican house studies here in
Washington DC we'll hear more about the
tomecek Institute at the end of our talk
he's originally a native of southeastern
Georgia
in father white study at Brown
University and then went on Oxford
University is the co-editor of the
academic journal Nova at veteran and an
ordinary member of the typical Academy
of st. Thomas Aquinas and his topic
think of its formal title is life living
in the pursuit of happiness a 13th
century take on natural rights father
I'd like to thank Matthew for that warm
and and gracious introduction and also
for that excellent conceptual segue
because the way in which he introduced
the theme of the talk is precisely the
way I wanted to begin which is by
considering what Thomas Aquinas might
say to another Thomas that being
Jefferson regarding the intelligibility
and meaningfulness of the opening lines
of the Declaration of Independence now I
am NOT a constitutional scholar and
don't know very much about the Lockean
versus Montesquieu Ian origins of the
founders crafting of that important
document but it has it has a way of
being that if you apply the light of
Aquinas to most thinkers it is in some
way felicitous and helpful so there's
nothing wrong with bringing some of st.
Thomas's thinking about nature and
happiness to bear on Jefferson so to
start with the opening line of the
Declaration of Independence that that
Matthew quoted it says we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they are endowed
by their creator with certain
inalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and again as he noted and I
was going to say it's he chose a term
which is a classical to you diamond Ian
ethics you find as somatic in
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics but also
a Gustin on the ethical life being a
life of the pursuit of happiness that to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent
the governed that whenever any form of
government becomes destructive to these
ends it is the right of the people to
alter or abolish it and to institute new
government laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in
such form as they as to them shall seem
most likely to effect their safety and
Happiness I really just want to hone in
on a couple of ideas here Jefferson are
the the authors of the document aligned
the idea of human nature with happiness
with the with the concept of what the
fundamental aims of government and life
in community are about that the measure
of the just actions of a government are
inherently grounded in and related to
the state's capacity to facilitate the
human search for happiness and that if
that search for happiness is in some way
undermined that is something contrary to
human nature which acts as a guard a
rail guard against unjust and tyrannical
government so there is a strong sense an
Enlightenment philosophical sense no
doubt of human nature as a certain kind
of guide or measure of just versus
unjust action and and government and
nature is deeply related to the mystery
the problem of the search for human
happiness I think we can call it a
problem because as we know the search
for human happiness is is complicated so
I'm gonna transition now to st. Thomas
and one of the most famous articles on
the moral teaching of Aquinas in Summa
this is from the premise of gunday or
the first part of the second part of the
famous Summa Theologiae where Aquinas is
talking about the foundations of natural
law and he asks questions in this
section about whether the natural law
can be eradicated in us so Agustin's
Aquinas has read a lot of Augustine and
he has a rather sober view of human
nature and he knows that human beings
can do a great deal damage to themselves
in their own moral conscience and that
whole civilizations can
lose track of fundamental precepts of
the natural law in major ways so in a
certain way the diagnostic question is
just how bad can it get or how much will
be left if you if you strip away
everything that could go and Aquinas has
some rather plausible views about what
most fundamental principles of human
agency remain no matter what in every
civilization and although I haven't
given it to you here the first place he
starts is every human action is in some
way motivated by the desire for
happiness
fundamentally we choose the good and we
reject what we consider to be evil and
we coordinate all our activities
rationally deliberatively in view of
seeking to be happy the good is what
will we perceive or think objectively
whether rightly or wrongly will Maxima
lies true authentic happiness and human
flourishing and the evil is that which
will not so it's a kind of practical
definition of good and evil as that
which facilitate human happiness or harm
it and then he goes on to say there's
some basic inclinations towards
happiness in us that are in eradicable
and this sounds a lot like what
Jefferson is getting at the idea that
human beings actions are motivated by
the deep inclinations we have toward
happiness and that tend to aim towards
stable goods goods that every human
civilization must provide or protect if
that civilization is to remain human so
I've given you here three paragraphs I
it's a long article of the Summa but I
took out some of the core substance of
it and I've given it to you here so we
can talk about it it's very basic I mean
he's looking for something basic that's
the point if you're if you read this and
you think he's going to miss the most
elevated lofty vision of natural law
that's the wrong idea he's trying to
tell us the most fundamental things we
will always find he says the the order
of the precepts of the natural law is
according to the order of natural
inclinations and he goes now to the most
fundamental inclination in the human
being he says because in man there is
first of all an inclination to good in
Corden's with the nature he has in
common with all substances in as much as
every substance seeks the preservation
of its own being according to its nature
and by reason of this inclination
whatever is a means to preserving human
life and of warding off its obstacles
belongs to the natural law it's very
basic
people like to be they like to not have
their hand held to the stove when it's
turned on they don't like sharp objects
coked into their body they dislike
having the flu and they tended to aim to
live and they tend to aim to avoid death
it's very minimalistic but it holds fast
to empirical experience now Aquinas has
a notion very like what we call the
notion well you know when you talk about
rites
it's a very contested word in our own
world today but Aquinas has a concept
that which is the kind of medieval
foundation of the notion of rites talk
which is the notion of the use jus what
is due to a person he thinks that every
human being has certain things due to
them based on the kind of nature they
have in the inclinations of their nature
so a fundamental use or a fundamental do
that we owe each person is to respect
their just inclination and capacity to
seek to live and to avoid being harmed
okay it's just very fundamental but is
it so under this first category come
things like the fundamental inclination
to wish for food clothing and shelter
and safety and security free act freedom
from any act of harm and we could speak
then in Aquinas way of thinking about
what is due to every human being and if
you like we could call that an a
metaphysical or ontological foundation
of Rights that every human being has an
inclination to want food security
shelter freedom from grave harm and
bodily integrity the preservation of
bodily integrity and that that gives
them a just civil right or what is due
to them in the order of Justice that
they should be free from those kinds of
harms
now I haven't of course said anything
about happiness in this capacity just
simple freedom from harm is not usually
a sufficient condition from hat for
happiness if it were the life of priests
would be so simplified our hours would
be shorter you would come to us and we
would feed you we do do that we're big
into food you know the priesthood but
the priests but we would it would just
be enough so we move on to the second
category there are brothers in the
dominican house for whom it's enough but
we're trying to elevate we're trying to
elevate secondly there is a man an
inclination to things that pertain to
him more specifically according to that
nature he has in common with other
animals and in virtue of this
inclination those things are said to
belong to the natural law which nature
has taught to all animals such as sexual
intercourse education of offspring and
so forth now this is a remarkable
passage you would think that Aquinas of
all people would have a very elevated
quasi angelic view of the human family
and would start from the spiritual
motives of human beings building
families up as parts of friendship and
mutual virtue and shared love no he says
look we're animals and animals tend to
couple and have children have offspring
and they tend to nurture their offspring
now the wit he doesn't he's presuming
that we can sort of have read some more
of the Summa and he knows that we we
also know that the human animal is going
through this in a rational way all right
so when you nurture your offspring as a
human being you have to teach them the
alphabet and the affability and some
obedience and eventually things that are
dreadful and torturous like math
but the point is that he's what he's
saying is the human beings that our
animals will tend to create these kinds
of features of any human civilization
where you find human beings in any
civilization you will find them coupling
and having children and caring about
their children and nurturing them and
there's a whole civil of sociological
development that that gives rise to so
this is part of the natural law too and
we could speak if we want to develop
this about the use or what is due to
every human being which is the right to
freely engage in marriage and the
education of their children in a certain
way Aquinas thinks that's grounded in
your animality that because you are an
animal you have the right to engage in
having children through marriage and
loving and educating the children you
have through marriage because it's a
very intrinsically human-animal thing to
do now there's of course distinctively
human or inhumane ways of acting towards
one's spouse and children so it's not
that he's minimalizing but he is saying
that this feature of human civilization
is in a certain way in radical you won't
really find a world in which this ceases
to happen I I know people will bring up
the Shakers but it didn't work and then
he says he goes to the more specifically
human spiritual features he said thirdly
there is a man an inclination to good
according to the nature of his reason
which nature is proper to him among the
animals and thus man has a natural
inclination to know the truth about God
that is amazing that's the first thing
he takes you have the human reason so he
goes to the summit of what's best in the
human animal which is that you're
capable of knowing God the highest
dignity of the human mind and to live in
society he's thinking about living in
society through rational freedom you
share the truth with other people where
you live in virtuous spiritual
friendship with other people and in this
respect whatever pertains to this
inclination belongs to the natural law
for instance to shun ignorance to avoid
offending those among whom one has to
live that's a very
Anakin way of putting it and other such
things regarding the above inclinations
okay so that's things like he's actually
saying now this don't get in don't go
too quickly into the question of a civic
rights because as a good Americans
you're gonna think well there's not a
civic right here father but he's
thinking about things like you have the
natural right not to be lied to
okay he's saying you have the natural
obligation to communicate the truth you
don't have to communicate every truth
but it's natural to use the capacity to
speak and communicate only to try to
seek the truth and communicate the truth
to live in the truth with other people
to live in virtuous friendship other
people here oh he's referencing here the
virtue of affability that's basically
trying to live without offending people
that's to treat people with kindness
Aquinas thinks affability is a dimension
of justice because every human being has
a fundamental human dignity and nobility
and beauty to them they are deserving of
being treated with affability he says
it's less than friendship but it's the
greatest disposition to friendship
if you treat your coworkers with not
just justice of the most rudimentary
kind but with genuine personal
affability you dispose yourself to
friendship with them so he's thinking
about these kinds of things the virtues
of affability justice life and community
and so we could talk here about the
right to seek the truth the right to
seek the truth the right to be justly
included in society I'm gonna try to
flesh that out a little bit more because
that's obviously a very complex notion I
mean to what extent is what do you mean
by inclusion okay but the point is that
there's a certain kind of human right to
be treated as a subject of dignity in
some very basic way and the right to
freedom of religion the right to pursue
knowledge of God now I'm going to
transition and I'm going to talk about
happiness and I want to I want to
transition by creating a problem or by a
outlet just identifying a problem and
the problem is this the things I just
named
you which are these sort of this laundry
list of kind of basic natural rights as
Thomas Aquinas understands them at least
as I'm interpreting him and saying you
could line him up rather nicely with
with the Declaration of Independence
that list of Rights is not really going
to procure profound human happiness per
se
okay so food clothing security the right
to freely engage in marriage and the
education of children we could add
public property right to private
property because families need private
property for the right upbringing of
their children the right to seek the
truth the right to some kind of affable
engagement with your fellow members of
society the right to freedom of religion
well I mean everybody mean most people
have something like that in our
immediate environment that doesn't mean
everyone's happy it's amazing actually
that the Bill of Rights sort of almost
suggests that the state would be
responsible for your happiness I was
having as I was thinking about preparing
this to talk Kafka esque dreams of
surreal short stories in which they
would take place in Prussia in the 19th
century and some some woman who has
studied a fair amount of the French
revolutionary literature comes and
opposes her complaint before the public
tribunal that the state has not provided
her with an adequate happiness and she's
she's suing them for that you know I
want my happiness after the Revolution
you owe it to me and it mean you could
just see Kafka getting into the the
absurdity of the human being well anyway
the point maybe it's more a Woody Allen
movie but the point is it's the pretense
the happiness is it doesn't devolve
immediately from the reclamation of
Rights we can give you lots of Rights
maybe even real ones and it won't
necessarily make you feel better because
you still have the natural problem of
human happiness
now when Aquinas turns to those human
happiness he does build it out of those
natural inclinations we have these
natural inclinations to say life in
society with others the
search for the truth knowledge of God
okay how is that then gonna flesh itself
out in an account of happiness the
problem is there are many wet things we
need to be happy and many of them are
not sufficient they're not they're not
fully adequate to procure our happiness
so I mean he has he has a I'm changing
now to the early part of the of the same
section of the Summa question to when he
says he asked the question what is it
that makes human beings happy I mean
this is the audacity of Aquinas he
really actually plans to answer this
question and if you read if you read
Prima second a question - he just goes
through methodically he actually starts
with wealth he first the first five
articles he lists problematic candidates
and by problematic candidates I don't
mean that these things aren't in some
way partial to procuring our happiness
partial answers but they're not adequate
answers you might say there's their
conditions seen akwonton
in some cases not in all they're not
sufficient conditions in any case so he
begins with artificial and natural
wealth he says artificial wealth is
things like money because it's an it's
an artefact that allows you to acquire
natural goods natural goods are actual
you know possessions physical things
external things now following Aristotle
Aquinas thinks a fair amount of natural
wealth is necessary for your physical
well-being so it comes under that first
inclination to security food and shelter
and for the conditions of a life in
society for example the life of a family
we can talk about whether a person's
wage is adequate to support their family
for example and that's an entirely
reasonable question of a minimum minimal
amount of natural and artificial wealth
but the point is this is a problematic
candidate for absolute happiness because
wealth although it has an allure to it
is fundamentally a means to permitting
life in community and so it can
alleviate a lot of stresses or it can
create sufficient conditions for a happy
life together with others but it isn't
really what procures the life of
soul of the happy the flourishing of the
soul in life with others so then he
moves on to honor fame or glory well
part of the problem with honor as with
fame and glory is they depend upon
others by the way this is so
interestingly borne out by instagram
aquinas if you if you um i don't know
who some of these people are but i get i
get junk mail and it tells me about
famous people who are they want me to
see new pictures of the minds to graham
and you might think well that that's
because they're spiritually vacant
people and they just have nothing to do
but live live lives out in some western
state of the country that will remain
unnamed for reasons of reasons um well
because my staff from california but
anyway but that basically um there's
something kind of spiritually vacant
about this and you could say to that but
there's actually something very
spiritually ambitious the problem about
being famous well because you're
beautiful or because you have been in
films or whatnot it's there's a lot of
upkeep and that's why there has to be a
lot of pote there have to be a lot of
postings that's what twitter is great
for people who need to keep up on honor
is about creating and sustaining
relations relationship aristotle says
are the most fragile of beings your
substance continues your relations are
always changing i mean i'm related to
all of you spatially like for about
another 20 minutes and then it's gonna
all dissolve the relations are fragile
they're inherently fragile ontologically
so if you if you maintain your happiness
through attachments to honor and fame
you need to always be cyclic emai naina
in renewing relations and that means you
you have to do a great deal of work and
it is ultimately all ephemeral and it
will all fall apart there's there's ways
to use that towards other things i
suppose in the interim like you could go
back to wealth but yeah the point is you
know some of those people need to read
the first three articles of Summa okay
anyway then he names power the okay
power is a better candidate because with
power you can actually affect the world
but the problem with power is it's
fundamentally a means of getting things
done so those who have power will do
well to use it rightly
to ordinate coordinate their own and
other people's lives in view of the
attainment of happiness but simple
exercise of power is not really a
sufficient condition for happiness now
we all know there are people some of
them you know famous figures in history
who thought power was an end in itself
or who it really got drunk off the lust
for power all these things have an
allure to them and you can basically try
to build them up as absolute candidates
for happiness but st. Thomas is trying
to argue and I'm just right curse lis
going over them he's trying to argue
these are this is not wise bodily goods
well he says you know we need a certain
amount of bodily goods but they don't
quench the deeper desires the spirit and
we do have deeper desires the spirit now
you do have the person who sort of
convinces themselves they don't know
they go to an analytic philosophy
department and they major in philosophy
and they become a materialist and they
decide that basically if they can just
make themselves happy materially it's
going to take care of everything in
their psyche all psychology and you know
they usually try something whether more
hedonist or epicurean and if you're a
priest you meet them on the other end of
that little exercise and it hasn't
worked out and Aquinas explains that why
he says you know all these things are
finite
they they they Accord some kind of
finite happiness that may be reasonable
and good I mean I like filet mignon as
much as the next person but the thing is
that this the human intellect has a
certain thirst for the infinite and even
for the infinite good and so there's
always going to be a kind of a spiritual
lassitude or incompleteness by just
attempting to anesthetize the mind
through the life of the senses and he he
goes on to talk about this in terms of
pleasures pleasures are two finite and
in transitory to provide profound rest
they can as it were days the mind with
they can they can maybe bathe the senses
and intense experiences for a time but
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't really
procure long-lasting happiness we all
know or have been the undergraduate who
just tries this experience on Friday and
Saturday nights and finds that the
work and the duties of life are still
there on Saturday afternoon and in fact
the existential disquiet so anyway then
we get the then we get the authentic
candidates and Aquinas doesn't list them
all in one place but he does he does
basically say it's goods of the soul you
do need a lot of these other things you
do need a certain amount of security and
natural goods and wealth but
fundamentally that the candidates are
the goods of the soul and he doesn't
list them all in this same article but
if you hunt around you find lists
basically different places
friendship spiritual friendship is for
Aquinas when you will the good of the
other person and when he or she wills
you're good when you both know it and
when you choose to live it through some
kind of collective activities okay so
it's not sufficient to say well we both
like to rob banks together and we're
both good at it I admire your bank
robbery skills I admire yours
you're very useful to me you're very
useful to me that's fine but that's not
spiritual friendship that's utilitarian
friendship so spiritual friendship where
you delight in the company and affection
of the other person and will their good
life and community then expands from
that basic notion through the FitLife of
the family and the broader ties of
society often animated by work and
artistic creativity human beings have a
natural practical intellectual 'ti they
like doing things that are artistic and
work-related that they they generates
meaning for them it's limited but deep
meaning the pursuit of the knowledge of
the truth religious happiness through
the worship and knowledge of God and a
final equines will give the supernatural
answers that he thinks are most ultimate
which are the life of grace and the
contemplation of God and he thinks
there's a kind of openness in the soul
where it can never find full rest except
ultimately to find rest in the grace of
Christ now here's the I'm transitioning
towards the end the airplane is
approaching the runway do not despair
you will soon be allowed to disembark
and ask questions and
escaped back to the the BBM the burgundy
but here's the fundamental transition
point of the talk and it really is in a
way where I want to not challenge
because that's not the point
I don't want to challenge the
Jeffersonian paragraph but but put an
important asterisks and the important
aspects is to note that most forms of
deep happiness come from goods possessed
in common now buy goods possessed in
common I don't mean the time share that
we have with our uncle in the keys
although actually that could be a means
towards happiness I mean it might be
better to give the example of when I
like my uncle and his family's is
fictional I like my uncle and his family
and you know my family and his family
enjoy vacationing together in the keys
and we've had some incredible family
vacations that are just a refreshment
for the soul that's what I'm talking
about the the shared life together
it's the common goods that typically are
the place where we find our deepest
happiness it's the common goods that are
typically the place where we find our
deepest happiness so we tend to think in
modern political philosophy not always
but if you read someone like Hobbes as
Leviathan or some other contemporary
theorists in terms of the state and the
individual it's the kind of binary units
of thinking about political rights and
political happiness there is the state
and there's every individual the
individual is a subject of rights the
individual subject is some way to the
state the state needs to provide for the
individual and there's all sets a whole
set of relationships that ensue it's not
that it's fundamentally false but it
just leads out all the middle terms of
these collective goods the collective
good of family life this is a certain
happy forms of happiness you can't have
except if you have together with other
people but you can't you can't it's like
the theory the product of the sort of
prodigal son' image you can't look at
your spouse one day and your children
and say honey children life with you is
so much
it's so happy there's so much joy here
and I'm enjoying it so much like this
collective friendship I'm just gonna
take my slice of the pie and leave and
enjoy it on my own because the problem
is then the the common good that's held
together by those sets of relationships
of common activities is eviscerated okay
so it's it's you you simply to sustain
the common life of happiness you have to
share in the common project this for
Catholic religious it's not your typical
example but for us it's the liturgy it's
you know try doing Gregorian chant with
two people or three people compared with
30 people it's a big difference when you
know when the choir is really you know
nimbly singing beautifully and you're
able to pray the Psalms or celebrate the
mass in a large collective environment
you have a very different result then if
everybody goes to their room and chants
on their own mm-hmm it would be disaster
so I mean there are there are forms of
religious life that do permit that that
you know you pray basically always on
your own but that you lose the
collective good okay so I'm here to give
examples now Aquinas talks and I'm
finishing but Aquinas talks about three
kinds of justice one is the the kind
that comes intuitively to almost anyone
when you ask about justice and that's
called commutative and that's basically
a usually relationship of equality of a
shared good so if I go into the store
and I want to purchase I don't know I'm
not used to this you know a can of two
some cans of tuna fish for because I
have to cook and that's how I cook so
the poor brothers and and I've got like
20 cans of tuna fish right and and then
I'm charged a thousand dollars for 20
cans of tuna fish well you know there's
there's something that's not against
that's against commutative justice there
should be some kind of equal measure of
pay to what the the good is worth so
basically usually commutative justice
has its primary an aligator arts kind of
typical example in economic purchasing
you know against economic exploitation
or you know you do a daze
work and how much do you get paid or
someone does a day's work for you and
how much do you pay them commutative
justice distributive justice is the more
typical kind of Philosopher's interest
in our own day and age which is what do
you owe the common good and what does
the common good only owe you and it's
the part to the whole so if you take
about like a question which special
needs child you have a child born with
important disabilities okay does the
state for that matter does the family
does the community have particular
obligations of justice to that child
that a less vulnerable child would not
receive absolutely so that child should
be distributed special and distinct
kinds of goods well you know or you have
a person who has particular talents
yeah and they they you know let's so you
go back to my example musical person you
have a musical person in your community
if you're in a religious community is it
reasonable to ask them to distribute the
injustice as part of their contribution
to the common life to produce beautiful
music for the community it could be
within within reason okay so there's
distributive justice is sort of the
messy on the equal forms of of
collaborative justice but then there's
another kind of Justice that Aquinas
mentions it's actually fundamentally
typical for him which he calls legal
sometimes called social justice when you
hear social justice if you from a modern
Catholic context you're typically
thinking actually about distributive
justice you're thinking well social
justice is the state needs to provide
mechanisms for the security and care of
those who are most underprivileged etc
that's actually distributive justice if
you use the term correctly social
justice is the rights and are the rights
and responsibilities of the persons who
who accede to life in a group it's
particularly that kind of collective
happiness I'm talking about like so for
example if you're part of a family I'm
talking about like a domestic family you
have certain rights and certain
obligations to inclusion in that family
and to commitment to that family
precisely to sustain the joy and
happiness of collective life with those
persons now these can be very
fat Sal that's I'll obligations easy
because they give you the greatest
happiness you know like the obligation
to attend regular prayers throughout the
day if you're Dominican or if you work
in a place that you like working okay
and you have a happy community with the
people you work with then you have a
kind of kind of happy obligation to
treat them humanely and and to live with
them in friendship and to enjoy working
to contribute in such ways to enjoy
working with them okay so this kind of
justice of living of inclusion in
projects of common good projects of
common goods and of being good in common
of enjoying the happiness of living in
community of various kind so where I
want to conclude is this if you follow
Aquinas as understanding of the
inclination to happiness and you look at
where he's identifying it friendship
life and community artistic creativity
pursuit of the knowledge of the truth
religious happiness we don't do this
stuff alone we do this in common in
common life with others of various kinds
we're here tonight to kind of talk about
the truth probably to fraternize a fair
amount and it's it's an attempt to
delight in the company of others in the
pursuit of the truth it's a collective
act okay so those basic inclinations in
us need to be respected by and facin in
certain way preserved Andrus and helped
by the state or by the local government
or by the local authority of say a
domestic family in its government to
provide those allow those inclinations
to flourish but and here's the key thing
if you have a uniquely individualistic
conception of happiness you cannot
understand adequately the obligations of
the state to respect the nature of the
common good and the common goods in the
plural that make people happy so you
could think about the median I'm talking
about like middle common goods that any
state needs to respect the fact the life
of the family the life of the church in
fact in some way the life of the
corporation or the small business with
its the the life of the art
the political think-tank it's a kind of
way of sharing in the search for the
truth and promoting it the University
you can complain about particular
universities their configurations in the
internal culture but the idea of a place
a common life where people pursue the
truth together that's a fundamentally
sound beautiful and good common good
that needs to be preserved facilitated
and sustained at least respected by the
state so I'm just gonna finish with this
last comment on your sheet natural
rights of institutions and common goods
don't per se come from the state nor are
they facilitated by the market now I'm
making a comment here against a kind of
mega collectivity of the left and maybe
a minimalist individualism of a
libertarian sort you can't just follow
Adam Smith's laws and expect necessarily
those common goods will actually they
may well arise but the market forces per
se need not respect them that doesn't
mean I'm not I'm not arguing for any
special protections for them simply say
I'm just rather say it's not like just
individualism and market forces generate
per se the common goods nor is it the
case the state can generate them on the
contrary they're natural and they are
presupposed there prior to both the
state and the and the in the market and
do they have to be in some way the goods
we aim to to facilitate our own
happiness in life in community with
others in the midst of the life of the
state and the market they have to they
proceed both and they have to be
acknowledged by both so I think
respecting and preserving people's
natural inclinations and therefore you
might call what is due to them or their
natural rights is deeply related to
respecting their collective forms of
happiness that they seek to live
together in in in particularly
typically human ways now thank you very
much I'm going to open the floor for
questions
yes sir it's you were first oh so we
have a question up here no so uh thank
you very much for the excellent lecture
I wanted to ask a question about that
one of those first clauses in the
Declaration of Independence dealing with
the self-evident nature of natural
rights and I thought it was very
interesting your connection in your
speech of the rights of property through
the rights of families to possess the
things necessary for the rearing of
children and I wanted to ask if there
was any other context that would be in
its in itself self-evident provable by
its own nature that could explain the
origin of property rights okay that's a
wonderful question so I think everyone
heard it but it's it's a it's about the
idea that property rights just
self-evident in the Declaration of
Independence now I'm I'm gonna be a you
know you go to the casino and you find
there are people gambling there and you
shouldn't be scandalized so if you talk
to Dominicans you might find they
sometimes prefer Aquinas is used to
others Aquinas actually asks this
question is it self-evident that
people's private property ought to be
respected and he talks about first-order
second-order and third-order precepts of
the natural law and he says only the
first order of precepts are self-evident
and he thinks among those are the basic
inclinations to habit that we should
seek to do the good as best we
understand it avoid evil and seek
happiness and that these basic
inclinations are inscribed in us the
inclination to try to survive the
inclination to life in the family and
the inclination to the truth to try to
find the truth and to live in some way
in society and that you can't really get
away from that you can take your most
despotic dysfunctional example of human
government in history and you'll still
find something like those self of an
basic
even though it's being selectively maybe
taking away from some people is being
preserved for others that's not to
justify it I'm just trying to say
there's a way in which it can't be
eviscerated even in the most acutely
immoral forms of government then he says
there's second-order precepts and he
there alludes to the ten commandments
and among them he puts the positive
precepts that correlates to the seventh
commandment thou shalt not steal I'm
getting it right the seventh the eighth
yeah thou shalt not steal the positive
correlation is that there's needs to be
a just respect of the private property
of others and he says funnily enough
talking about this he says but it's
certain times and places this instant
this understanding of the second order
precept has not been self-evident to
people and there have been whole
governments or tribes that have stolen
and taken the property of others in
unjust ways so Aquinas thinks he uses
the language of self-evident to mean
that it really could not fail to be seen
but as we know from say for example the
20th century with communism it can be
failed it can fail to be seen by some
people now he does think that
second-order precept follows pretty
carefully from the first-order precept
so he thinks he thinks most reasonable
people will come to see it he says
fairly intuitively and if they're taught
it will it will it will confirm their
reason very usually with fairly happy
happily but he wants to be able to
explain how it can be eviscerated now
this came up in the 19th century
particularly in Pope Leo the 13th
disputes with communism and socialism
and in I think it's 1891 hopefully or
the 13th published an incredibly
important people encyclical that was a
historic import for all of modern Europe
which is called raw rerum Novarum new
things basically and it's an engagement
with the argument of communism and
socialism that modern civic society and
the church have not done enough to
facilitate the amelioration of life
conditions of people under the
in the industrial revolution and that
the the best way to procure the
happiness of the working class is to
dissolve private property and have
redistribution occur by the means of the
state I mean you're getting the rise of
the socialist communist movement and he
is extremely tenacious in arguing for
the necessity of the right of private
property for the maintaining of the
dignity and integrity of the individual
and he says it's even more incumbent for
the family so it's very interesting that
leo xiii set argues that although each
individual may have a right to private
property which he says it is it is it's
there it's necessary for any individuals
autonomy when you begin to see these
into what I'm calling these median
common Goods and he thinks the family is
the most basic common good because it
provides life for society and the
fundamental sort of matrix of education
and love of children then you have an
even more incumbent strengthening of the
natural right to private property in
other words he thinks like the family
has more right to private property than
the individual even though they both
have the right
that's not a very typical contemporary
way of thinking but it makes a lot of
sense you know to say that the higher
the stakes the more the rights are acute
I interned on Capitol Hill and I asked a
very senior member of leadership on on
the house side a question about their
faith and poverty my question to you is
is where does the line go between the
church government and what Aquinas says
and what you've talked about and where
the church and government should go
towards combating poverty and where you
think the common individual should have
a role in that I've been thinking about
this and this is something that that I
know the house leadership along with
members of members of the administration
are thinking about so this is a question
that I've had and if you could answer it
that'd be great thank you it sounds like
a Dodge to say that my expertise is not
in modern Catholic social justice theory
but really what all I want to say is
that what I'm about to say is the the
imperfect conjectural musings of someone
who specializes in systematic theology
and not moral theology okay but a couple
of thoughts here first of all the line
is always moving about what is possible
in light of more than just technological
development or medical development but
also the particular configurations of
society at any one time so a lot of the
argument about what can or ought to be
done is based on complex circumstances
in which intelligent people can disagree
about priorities so I mean you could
take the question of emergent medical
technologies and the treatment of are
rampant virus okay so take take a
rampant virus you're trying to treat but
then add in this complexity on the one
hand we have the technology and we can
mass-produce it on the other hand it's
become prohibitively expensive to
mass-produce it without also neglecting
what we produce with regards to some
other medical remedy okay so now we're
into an extremely complex proportional
calculus and there are going to be
intelligent people now just to expand
that
to go from the sector of the economy
that the piece of pie that goes to
health care for people for the indigent
versus trying to help the indigent who
have drug addictions trying to talk
about job creation programs how do you
cut up those pieces of the pie so I'm
just trying to say there's there's
always gonna be some very great
difficulties about practical
applications the church since the 19th
century has developed this body of
modern social justice doctrine in part
to look at these complex cases in real
time
she has tended to insist on a number of
you might call them ideal goals I mean
usually she uses a language of Rights I
think it's often more helpful to talk
about ideal goals but basically the
right and responsibility of every adult
capable person of working so you know
normally an adult person has a
responsibility to contribute this larger
society by working but we could talk
about it as also a capacity or right
that the state should seek to facilitate
so a state should seek to just to have
the goal of job growth that's a fairly I
think modest claim the church is
insisted on the right of education now
that's very tricky there is a right to
education education is often how you
fight indigent see and scholar eyes
people get them involved in the job
market but then how I mean how high is
the bar and how why do you want to go
and how international do you want your
aims to be because a lot of problems of
international poverty are also about
lack of education the church has always
been very engaged in providing for the
common good in terms of health care
hospitals education and food clothing
and shelter as well as spiritual care
obviously that's something that our
modern governments typically don't look
at at all about this sort of spiritual
religious care of persons you know I
think with
to say for example I think the church is
going to tend to think that there it is
it is in a modern in a modern
nation-state of the European or American
sort where you have adequate health care
in principle to allow each human being
access to medical care you need to fit
need some kind of system that
facilitates access that doesn't
necessarily mean the government has to
provide it or ought to although there
are people who argue that and I have a
lot of problems with some of the why
consider the religious the anti
religious elements of Obamacare and
maybe I have some ambivalence about the
way Obamacare has been done as well as
its fiscal question of fiscal
responsibility but but if you take a
much simpler case if you if you have
someone who is found gravely ill who
comes into an emergency room and they
don't have insurance in the hospital
refuses to serve them even though they
are gonna there and then they die I
think that the Catholic Church would say
that that's you know a an act of grave
injustice to the person now how do you
build out from that a larger case about
trying to have proportion access to
right you know help good forms of health
I think a lot of these things don't then
come down to deep prudential
disagreements one example is the just
wage leo xiii emphasized in the face of
the modern industrial revolution that
children should not be forced to work 16
hours a day that they needed to be
educated that men who were in full their
full health could be asked to work
longer hours than women who worked
typically having children and then
children and that there had to be what
he called a living wage so that if you
had a single typically you had one
person in the family working that person
needed not should not be exploited but
should be paid enough that they could
support their wife and children a lot of
our notions now of minimum wage are the
results of you know those kinds of
impetuses to keep people from being
manipulated in desperate circumstances
in an industrial Europe in the 19th
century so now you take a question like
raising minimum wage today I went and I
was asked to do something on this on
EWTN and I wouldn't read the Catechism
it's very interesting there's two
principles there there's the universal
obligation the state of this
State to try to create work for everyone
and there's the obligation of the state
to try to facilitate a just living wage
for everyone
now the two principles can act almost
mathematically directly against one
another you could raise that you could
raise the minimum wage to $25 an hour
and you would create massive
unemployment you can lower it and you
can create more employment and so you
know you've got one party that's going
to talk about a lower minimum wage to
try to have a healthy you know life of
small businesses and wider employment
you've got another party that's going to
talk about trying to increase the
minimum wage it they're not you know in
terms of leo xiii teaching they're both
right but intelligent people are gonna
disagree about which economic proposals
are realists to try to help the most
people maximally so you see i avoided
ever taking a party line
thank you very much oh I didn't know you
okay we know you've got the microphone
Amy talk first uh my question about in
the articles you were referencing on
natural law when Aquinas addresses how
the natural law whether it can be
eliminated from the human heart and
which in what ways the natural law
becomes obscured or sedimented can you
perhaps speak to the ways in which that
can happen and how that can impact
rights talk as we're both fairly far
removed from the two mystic
understanding of Rights even though you
might not have called them that and
happiness and Jeffersonian mmm-hmm and
how our understanding of the pursuit of
happiness today has perhaps obscured our
habits a pursuit have obscured the
natural law yeah yeah well I mean I mean
the problem the problem is in some ways
you do have new situations in which you
do need to talk about rights and
responsibilities in new ways in new
contexts but you also have let's say the
cultural creation of Rights that could
be very contestable take a case that no
one will hear will be a surprise that I
would bring up which is the right to
human life from conception to natural
death and other people think that
there's a natural right to our human
right social right legal right abortion
okay so there you've got two conceptions
of Rights talk that are inimical to one
another mutually incompatible
fundamentally or yeah I think
fundamentally incompatible and that are
both aiming at one of the same subject
of nature you know the pregnant woman
right so you have deep discord about
what we mean by rights there's you know
so in a way I think what you're alluding
to by the question is to what extent can
moral blindness set into a culture to
such an extent that we not only fail to
see what true natural rights are but we
create or generate the language of human
rights in ways that obscures the reality
of nature alright so actually the
language of natural right
is now becoming an obstacle to the right
perception of natural rights rights talk
against real natural rights and I do
think that if you're for example
convicted about the fact that the human
life individual human life begins at
conception and has an inherent natural
dignity that should not be violated then
you have to conclude that that's what's
happening and that's and so I on the
other hand I would just say part of the
answer is to try to go back and look at
what a human being is and I do agree
with john paul ii in the encyclical very
fetus Adagio that the fundamental crisis
behind moral confusion our own age is a
crisis of the truth the human being is
capable of the truth and the human being
is capable of grave confusion about the
truth and so I think just simply
following our own intuitions and
instincts is never enough we do need to
go back and try to examine what we think
the structure of reality is and I I do
think Aquinas important guide for
helping us to track onto reality
intellectually and get back in touch
with natural rights yes sir the natural
urge to procreative sexual intercourse
and the education of offspring could you
flesh out for us how that leads to the
family and not some sort of brave new
world situation as I think you know we
all have friends who don't yet on the
paper here but not what we think right
right right so I mean the intrinsic
connection between human coupling and
sexual intercourse and having children
and then committing to raise those
children and then in a you know a
committed family context and that's
profoundly compromised in our own time
the perception of that we just come back
to this I mean oh actually I was just
going for something rather minimal here
which was to say that there will always
be many people in civilization who ten
to eventually choose to have children
and to raise them or seek to raise them
as couples so that's a very it's a very
modest statement now when I was talking
to the other question the first question
about self-evident truths another
example Aquinas gives of an of a second
order precept that can be the face from
the human mind is the thou shalt not
commit adultery the positive precept was
human sexualities in some way
fundamentally oriented toward the loving
commitment to another personal
procreation and the loving commitment to
another person in a procreative
relationship open to life where you have
children and raise them how you know
actually as a priest strangely I'm
optimistic about this in in common
culture because I see it triumph over
all the ideologies in the end they often
through after a long time and with a lot
of confusion and some errors along the
way but it tends to be the case that
people actually do settle on this
conception or at least they aspire to it
not in every case there are people who
live very consistently ideologically
opposed lives to that principle for long
duration but rare and and sometimes they
capitulate with agony to the fact that
they've had a mistaken conception so
when he says why are the second-order
precepts often in this array that are
like obscured for us he gives different
reasons so he says sometimes it's the
vehemence of the passions and sometimes
it's ideology it's might more modern
word but basically air speculative
errors of reason so if you've got a so
first of all you know I mean Aquinas is
an Augustinian so he thinks the vehement
passions of human sexual attraction
often confound human reason this is true
then so you you know when you act when
you have of that bit and then you've got
the technological production of forms of
contraception allow people do not live
committed marital relationships for long
periods of time which were generated in
part because of the vehemence of the
sexual appetite and then you have the
ideological belief that it's okay to you
referred to brave new world it's okay to
radically reconfigure couplings both on
one side of
menu the way people couple sexually and
the other side of menu the way they
choose to reproduce then you can have a
lot more kind of deep confusion at least
for Aquinas Aquinas view of these things
it settles in but it is hard to
eradicate the not the deep natural
inclination of people to want to have
children with someone they love and to
raise those children with someone they
love and it doesn't end to persevere in
them as a deep norm so I think as Rabbi
Jonathan Sacks says it's if you're in
the marriage business it's a good time
to invest because people are always
going to want the product
Thank You Father Thomas Joseph for that
wonderful talk
I'm Paul ray for those who don't know me
I'm the president of the DC chapter of
the domestic Institute and you've been
here for the final lecture in our you
can you hear me is that better Thank You
Beatrice you've been here for the the
final lecture in our series on politics
and the philosophy of st. Thomas so big
thank you also to to Matt Spaulding and
to to the Kirby Center posting the
series now as you know if you've been
here the domestic Institute exists to
promote Catholic truth in our
contemporary world
by strengthening the intellectual
formation of Christians at universities
in the church and in the wider public
square the photo st. Thomas Aquinas the
universal doctor of the church is our
touchstone
as you may have gathered the domestic
Institute is part of the been difficult
Faculty of the Immaculate Conception of
the Dominican House of studies here in
Washington and if you don't know
anything about that ask any of the men
in white next month we are shifting
gears and hosting a talk by father
Thomas Joseph entitled can Beauty save
the world Aquinas on art and literature
I don't want to presume what father's
answer will be but I think it might be
yes and I heard him give the minister
version his lecture a few months ago and
it was extraordinary so I encourage
everyone to go the lecture will be at
st. Charles Borromeo Church in Arlington
on April 26 at 7:00 p.m. so without
further ado we'd like to invite you all
to adjourn in just a moment but I
believe Matt Spaulding has a word aside
thank you I also just wanted to in
addition to allowing the great pitch for
the domestic institute and happy to host
all of you here again in the future
thank the mystic Institute and father
father dominic for these wonderful talks
and since we don't have another to
Michigan's to talk to bring to your
attention I will invite you all to join
us next Tuesday evening when Michael
Walsh great social critic is speaking on
his book here entitled The Devil's
pleasure palace the cult of critical
theory of the sort subversion of the
West and that'll be a wonderful event I
bring you to Jan I hope you join us
for future Kirby events here as well and
just in closing since that's we do I
would draw your attention to additional
proof of this wonderful talk to George
Washington's first inaugural address
where he makes it very clear that by
happiness he points out that there is no
truth more thoroughly thoroughly
established in the economy and course of
nature that there is a connection
between virtue and Happiness that's his
first inaugural address for the first
president so with that I thank you again
and please join us for the reception